but tonight we begin with the Washington
swamp where Biden's balloon Saga it is
now on week three and it is getting
nuttier by the day now today's
developments raise far more questions
than you could ever imagine now earlier
your president Joey uh the president of
the United States finally said something
about the other three objects besides
the Chinese uh spy balloon that he
decided to shoot down over North America
airspace last week with four hundred
thousand dollar missiles that you paid
for but don't expect any Clarity from
Joe Biden now here is the truly
frightening part Joe has absolutely no
idea he told us today none at all
whatsoever what these objects were where
they came from what they were doing he
has no idea what he ordered our military
to shoot down I am not making this up
this is what he said earlier today take
a look
we don't yet know exactly what these
three objects were but nothing nothing
right now suggests they were related to
China's spy balloon program or that
there were surveillance vehicles from
other any other country
the intelligence community's current
assessment is that these three objects
were most likely balloons tied to
private companies Recreation or research
institutions studying weather or
conducting other scientific research
think about this he doesn't know what he
even shot down but he's very very
confident it wasn't from China how on
Earth would he possibly know it's not
from China especially after the first
Chinese spy balloon uh they should be
the number one suspect in my mind they
are the number one suspect then he says
they could be research balloons okay
does anyone here actually believe that
um well tonight there are unconfirmed
reports that one of the three objects
may have been a 12 dollar high altitude
balloon now missing from an Illinois
based hobby Club maybe did we spend four
hundred thousand dollars to shoot that
balloon down so let me get this straight
it took by eight days to shoot down a
known Chinese spy balloon that they said
they they knew this was coming from the
moment of takeoff it traveled into
Alaska airspace down the west coast of
Canada into Idaho then over our nuclear
silos in Montana then sensitive military
installations in Kansas Missouri
Kentucky North and South Carolina and
right off the Atlantic coast where they
finally shut it shut it down after they
got all the intelligence they could have
ever dreamed of but with three random
floating objects that might be
researched balloons or 12 balloons from
a hobby club or something else Joe
doesn't know our president ordered the
shooting down of an object that he has
no idea what he shot down and by the way
he shot them down in two cases of a
population centers to boot isn't that
something that he claimed last week his
military said and he reaffirmed this
today that he wasn't supposed to do so
he had no idea what the objects were
when he gave the order to blast them out
of the sky five hundred thousand dollar
missiles by the way one of the missiles
missed so it took eight hundred thousand
dollars to shoot down one of the
unidentified objects which NORAD is even
suggesting and can't rule roll out it
may be alien related
okay beam me up Scotty uh but now think
how stupid for a second here just stand
back and think about how the world is
viewing this think how other nations are
viewing this I see this and I heard this
president today
and as an American I just felt nothing
but sheer embarrassment watching Joe
Biden as weak disorganized confused
frail incompetent it was it was
downright humiliating and embarrassing
and it even got worse take a look
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
sir there's been criticism there's been
criticism that this wasn't there's been
criticism that this really trying to
compromise by your family's business
relations Sir Mr President Mr President
there has been criticism
Mr President there has been criticism
that this was an overreaction that was
done because of political pressure
to turn my off and that's the question
when you have more polite people
he did right now think about this Joe
Biden said this was not a big deal this
is not a problem this was not a massive
breach echoed By His Brilliant giggling
vice president Kamala Harris he then
shuffles back into a back room without
answering a single question so we have
Mr lying dog face pony soldier president
uh Biden uh valuing politeness uh of
course we all know what's going on here
Joe Biden is not mentally capable of
answering any tough questions especially
about his family's very deep Financial
ties to China we need answers because we
the American people have a right to know
how much money in business did Joe
Hunter and Jim Biden and the rest of
them do what the Communist Chinese are
they bought and paid for are they
compromised what compromising materials
might the Chinese and the Russians and
the ukrainians and other countries have
on the former crack addict that was
doing these deals for Daddy and giving
daddy half his income that would be
Hunter Biden to Joe those questions are
not relevant to us they are now for
eight long days Joe Biden did nothing as
China hovered over our nuclear sites our
military bases collected untold amounts
of data and when it was all said and
done he reassured his friends in the
Communist Party of China it's no big
deal Joe's words this was not a major
breach if that's not a major how many of
you think this is a major breach if you
think I think it's a major breach
you're giggling vice president Kamala
Harris said that it won't impact our
relationship in any way why not now in
the meantime the Communist Chinese they
are threatening us they're foaming at
the mouth they're berating the Biden
Administration they're livid and
apoplectic that Joe Biden actually shot
down their spy balloon over our
territory and they're even threatening
the United States with retaliation in
their minds they're acting as if we flew
a spy balloon over China and Joe just
sits there and takes it and shows the
world nothing but weakness it really
makes you wonder who Biden answers to
it's certainly not we the American
people now as we speak China maintains
ownership of thousands of Acres of
Farmland Ranch Land all across the
country did all of you know that
thousands and thousands of Acres I'd
like to buy thousands of Acres of Ranch
Land and farmland in China you think
they're going to sell it to me I doubt
it now that includes by the way 300
acres near Grand Forks Air Force Base in
North Dakota fifteen thousand acres uh
near Laughlin Air Base uh that's in
Texas China also owns land near nuclear
sites in Montana more land close to an
Air Force Base in Wyoming and fifteen
thousand acres of land near our nation's
capital in the Commonwealth of Virginia
for now now if Joe had any courage at
all he would confiscate all of that land
he would do it in the name of National
Security and he would do it for free and
take it as a partial payment for the
covet Devastation that the Communist
Chinese Unleashed on this country and
the entire world and lied about it thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else